foreign
folks welcome to this special dark horse
presentation of uh gifts for the holiday
season post Thanksgiving
pre-Christmas that sort of thing indeed
a special short edition of Dark Horse
today uh which we're going to talk about
a few things that we love but which are
not sponsors
uh and so we're just gonna launch right
in except to say that immediately
following this we're going to have our
private monthly q a for patrons at my
patreon so you can find in the notes a
link to my patreon if you're interested
in being part of a q a that's fairly
intimate that we have every month on the
last Sunday of the month except next
month when it'll be the penultimate
Sunday of the month so as not to be
talking on Christmas yeah we do silent
Christmas
Brett does sound like yes I try for a
while we thought it was just being
Sullen but no it was intentional
so we're actually going to start
um but with a few short readings from a
piece that I wrote with our friend and
colleague Drew schneidler back in uh
well I publish it to Natural Selections
to my sub stack in December of last year
just about a year ago called from silk
to pastries gifting Traditions across
time space and species since we wanted
to come to you and share a few things
that we like if you are in a situation
where you enjoy uh enjoy gifting
Traditions but really we didn't want
this just to be about hey here's some
stuff yep right so
um this is I
like I wrote it I recommend this piece
and it's also linked in the show notes
already but I'm going to start by
reading a few pieces from it and I don't
want you to share my screen here's that
because I'm reading it from a PDF
okay from silk to pastries gifting
Traditions across time space and species
he approaches her focused but tentative
she is yet to be convinced but he is
intent on winning her favor he brings to
her a nuptial gift a delicious nugget
wrapped in beautiful silk it is both
nutritional and it has both nutritional
and aesthetic value and the silk Carries
On It sensory messages that she is meant
to find highly compelling if she
approves of his gift she will likely
approve of him the perfectly chosen gift
can open many doors
a frog built a nest in the mud for his
intended a place that will stay wet for
his eggs and tadpoles when the rains
don't come but we but will be resistant
to floods when the water comes too fast
such a gift simple as it may seem is in
high demand these Gladiator frogs so
named for the impressive spines on their
wrists fight territorial Interlopers
they can be fierce and Savage when a
female Gladiator frog approves The Nest
that the male has built which she
accepts his gift there is therefore the
implicit promise of something more to
come the gift is not just the thing but
the defense of the thing as well in the
future should it come to it he will
defend what he built and is given to her
in so doing he will make it more likely
that their offspring will survive long
enough to metamorphose long enough to
play this game the same game with others
a future a few paragraphs later chapters
it's not that long
um and you can interrupt if you want a
few paragraphs later we talk about
some people rather than frogs and
spiders among the Kung San a
hunter-gatherer people of Africa's
Kalahari Desert material possessions are
few the small bands of 10 to 30 people
frequently move camp taking with them
everything they own permanent objects
are owned by individuals rather than by
a collective yet most such objects are
gifted frequently enough that they
become part of a network of goods in
which who gave what to whom when is
carefully monitored by all involved you
may pass along the ostrich shell jewelry
that I gave you yesterday before the
week is out but unlike the ever maligned
Christmas fruitcake in some American
households rapid re-gifting is expected
among the song thus there are delayed
reciprocal obligations between people
which helps to ensure good relations
frequent travel between the members of a
far-flung network and cooperation during
times of hardship this gift-giving
network function to spread risk more
evenly across the population and is so
integral to the Kong economy that it has
a special name xaro which I may be
mispronouncing
we apologize to our Chrome viewers
yes yes we do that's a standing apology
yes absolutely yeah
and finally from near the end of the
essay
after after we've talked a bit about uh
gifting among various various types of
people including weird moderns
historically the value of a gift was
easier to evaluate the sources of wealth
were fewer and easier to track the
acquisition of material was harder to
Outsource as was time spent time being
Zero Sum there are only so many hours in
a day any time spent by a giver creating
or procurring a gift was therefore in
direct competition with the business of
daily survival
a gift therefore was a sacrifice at some
level all told it was fairly easy to
evaluate the value of a gift relative to
the wealth of the individual the Rarity
of the material compared to the local
environment and the amount of time
invested
today's landscape is more ambiguous
wealth and its indicators are Myriad and
often difficult to evaluate or track
gifting is weakened by the ubiquity of
mass-produced indicators of wealth and
time is easily outsourced to the less
powerful
all of this has allowed markets to
provide material Goods with the
trappings of high value but at low
actual cost of the Gift Giver we are
biased all of us conscious or not
towards finding the most bang for our
buck towards giving something that is of
higher value than what we ourselves had
to spend for it
but because the recipients of our gifts
live in the very same world with the
same ever-present Marketplace they have
access to the same sales and discounts
as we do and so when ours race begins in
which quantity replaces quality the
demand for greater volumes of material
goes up is the value of the material
goes down and the global nature of these
Mass consumer goods facilitates the
transfer of resources from impoverished
Nations to wealthy ones all of this
makes more remote our ability to
honestly evaluate a gift and decouples
gifting from anything of True Value or
sacrifice we are thus undermining an
ancient source of bonding and social
cohesion
that's is that the last piece you're
going to share that is brilliant and I
don't know how it is that I have not
read this piece somehow I missed it um
yeah that's that's amazing and uh your
point about the meaning that is
inherently built into gifts because you
can know how rare the material is and
how long it would have taken to produce
it and something of the history of its
being transferred and things like this
uh and that our modern world just drives
our ability to assess these things to
noise I mean right it's an amazing point
thank you and I you know
the the few things that we want to talk
about today are mostly
um
maybe entirely ultimately uh with the
exception of our book which we're going
to mention here
um you know the products you know our
book was the product of a small local
producers because we wrote it but it's
obviously published by a you know a
major a major International publisher
um but all of the rest I think here are
we we focused on things that are made
um by individuals who exist you know who
are localized in space and time and we
have always had a bias towards the local
wherever we are and that means that when
we travel we buy things from local
Artisans and when we move to a new place
we seek out local producers of food and
of of craft and of other things that we
might find useful or beautiful to have
in our lives and so we have a couple of
local to us now things to recommend and
at least one uh local to us in Portland
um and the the the main thing that we
want to suggest here
Beyond sort of having a sense of what
gifting is you know many people feel a
sense of obligation that it's onerous
like oh my God it's this thing now that
I have to now I have a list of people I
just have to buy things for and that
that really degrades the ancient and far
more ancient than us modern humans far
more ancient than humans tradition of
gifting and that's why we start and then
end actually with evidence of gift
traditions in spiders in frogs in Birds
right there is and it you know yes it
comes with less cultural baggage but not
none uh and you know in spiders maybe
but in Birds this cultural package yeah
there's presumably nine spiders
that's right but yeah it comes it comes
with meaning and
um
the idea that the tradition of gifting
has now
outlasted in some sense the ability to
evaluate the meaning of these things and
so struggling to find something that
actually does have meaning is now kind
of the trick I mean in some sense maybe
that's even what's happened is that a
meaningful gift is now not so much
encoded in what it's made of and uh how
much time it took the person to make
because in general we don't make them
but the question is how you know what
was your investment in looking right
like how how successful you were you at
modeling the person's mind and figuring
out what it is that they would value
right which is also not easy to
interpret but uh but nonetheless the the
meaning has moved to another place
because the place where it used to
reside has been gamed yes and um well
one thing that I learned in researching
that piece on gifting Traditions is that
in some parts of Iran uh traditionally
there has have been very distinct and
formally distinct traditions of public
versus private gifts and public versus
private gifting and so sort of the I
don't remember what it is but there's
like an analogy to the American
fruitcake that gets constantly re-gifted
whereas in America it's a joke right
it's a joke for sitcoms and presumably
there are some fruitcakes that this
happens to and presumably a lot of
people who receive fruitcakes don't
actually like fruitcakes and so you know
that there is this ridiculous joke
uh but in Iran there is there is a
tradition of actually re-gifting public
gifts even pastries so loggers are
relatively recent like you know you you
can't re-gift it Beyond when the person
receiving it could plausibly enjoy it
themselves
um but re-gifting even of fresh food
items if it's a public gift under
certain circumstances is it acknowledged
part of the gifting tradition and that's
that's fascinating right and in part in
part what I you know never having been
to Iran not not knowing much beyond what
I read a year ago about that particular
tradition or or or the people involved
my sense is that part of what it does
just like with the Kung whom we also
haven't visited but about which I've
read a lot more and have more Decades of
experience thinking about
um what the act of giving does which is
also very much not the case in many
modern situations is I come to you I you
know the act of giving for like the the
Kung
uh is I have to make the Trek I have to
make the Trek to you in order to give
this to you because it is it is now time
for me to give you a thing but what that
really serves is like actually I get it
I gotta come see you I have to be with
you I have to be with you in person and
that points out then that the gift is
actually
my presence right that we are we are now
together and this is simpatico with the
idea we don't have really any of them
here on our on our list for today but
that
while often more expensive and more
personal and it's harder to get it
exactly right the gift of experience or
promise of time together
um or you know shared something together
a meal
flight lessons you know like
um a trip a trip yes and I was gonna say
you know I think I think that the best
gift I ever gave to you was an
experience learning how to actually
build from scratch
you didn't smelt yours I did not smelt
yours
um a bicycle frame which you designed
and actually built right and now it is
my primary bike and every time I ride it
that uh gift is revived and made very
very real right and it was you know this
is the United Bicycle Institute which
still exists in uh in Ashland and I
think it still has a branch campus in
Portland Oregon I think they've stopped
bike building in Portland they've
stopped the branch campus okay yeah
something something
um
and
you know it was something that you knew
about I didn't surprise you like oh you
want to do this like you would you had
been thinking about this for a long time
but it was at that point in our lives
for your 40th birthday and it was a lot
of money for us uh and it wasn't
something that you felt I think yeah
that you could really I could do and
that you were sort of free to spend
familial money on something that was
that was just for you and it also
um
you know the gift was also encoded in
the I will man the home front while you
are off doing this thing that you value
yeah right and so anyway it was a very
it was a very deep gift yeah I mean it
also I guess
um you know I was then in the habit of
running these study abroad trips so I
think I think indeed earlier that year I
had I had been running a study abroad
trip for five or seven weeks and you
were solo parenting with our then very
young children yeah they were like three
and five I don't think this is why
they're so messed up but it could also
don't think it's solely responsible for
why they're so awesome
probably not
um but yeah in part it was absolutely
like this is you know this is this is no
more
your responsibility than mine we we
co-parent we have we are family we have
family together and
um I recognize that even though that was
part of my work it was a choice that I
made to make that part of my work and
and and here you are here here is a gift
to some of your own time back yeah um
free from the obligations that we both
love and have chosen but still our
obligations
so with all that
um
and I guess I've already said I've
already spoken to this any locally
produced value-added food or drink
really and anything that you find that's
made by a producer either when they
produce it themselves and then turned it
into
uh you know they they grew the peppers
and they dried them and smoked them and
chopped them up and put them into jars
nicely nicely labeled and are selling
those at the farmer's market next to the
whole Peppers right that's that's a
terrific example and in fact there's one
of those happening right here in the in
the San Juan Islands and at the moment
and you know there will be many many
such things and you will be very likely
to find the smaller producers precisely
there at the farm at farmers markets and
at co-ops especially at farmers markets
and most farmers markets will have a
holiday
a a holiday I want to say episode that's
not right
um Edition something moment right
I meant when they come back yeah I don't
know what in any way Event Event sure
all right um I'm particularly fond at
the moment of shrubs uh which are fruit
infused vinegars fruit infused drinking
vinegars and you can just add them to a
bit of sparkling water to make a
delightful sharp Tangy fruity
refreshment or uses a mixer in a
cocktail
um there are a couple local to us
there's Carrie's elixirs which doesn't
seem to really have the capacity yet to
sell remotely but if you're local you
can get them and then girl meets dirt
and that's a link that's in the um it's
in the show notes and they do have a
site and they will ship and um and
they're doing terrific work that that we
recommend and I forgot to I have a
little
I have some things right next to me and
I forgot to bring one of those I'm so
glad that vinegar has come into its own
um it's such an underrated uh ingredient
highly variable highly useful in
adjusting Foods oh yeah so many things
you taste you're like okay that wants a
touch of salt that wants a touch of acid
rightness something and lemon juice
vinegar the key to a good marinade is
way more vinegar than you think yeah you
want because it doesn't reside there so
anyway it is good stuff and the idea
that it has come come uh into its own
with respect to uh so this is yeah this
is not girl meets dirt this is Carrie's
elixirs which is hard to see on the
camera of course and it looks like this
came out of the fridge they don't
they're shelf stable for at least a
little while they've already gone bad by
the time you get them
that we love this stuff right now
absolutely
uh yeah I I agree and I was um you know
it's interesting how our senses change
over time and that that I feel like
warrants a whole conversation on a
regular episode frankly but my color
sense changes my color preferences
preferences change with season with mood
but also as I age and my palette has
definitely changed and there are a
couple of things that I could not abide
when I was younger a lot of ferments
think like kimchi being the perfect
example yeah you would buy caramel
machines like what what is it why would
you do that why does the house smell
like this and I love it now and you know
I'll put there's actually a local
producer of kimchi and Anacortes and I
can't remember her name but you can go
in there and buy any I should have had
that here and uh a bit of her one of her
seasonal kimchi's on top of just a fried
rice that you've made is wow kimchi is
is so marvelous and again highly
variable really really interesting stuff
um I do find that
um flavors is a place
where value there are two different
kinds of value right there's Rarity
value right saffron is hard to get and
very expensive
um same thing vanilla also actual but
the number of things that are underrated
because they're not rare is amazing in
this space and it's like you know how
important is saffron to your cooking if
you had a tremendous amount of it would
you use it all that often probably not
on the other hand black pepper is so
underrated and the difference in quality
between black peppers
is immense right if you've got some old
black pepper it has almost no flavor in
it right but especially especially if it
was ground more than a little time ago
right yeah surface area issues so anyway
it's a it's a great Testament to the
idea that your actual value in terms of
how delicious something is is now
uncorrelated to the difficulty you know
you don't need a fleet with the you know
an armada to protect it to deliver you
the saffron to make the thing you know
peppercorns are easily available and
good ones aren't that expensive and it
makes a huge difference yeah and I think
um
I'm curious about the history of spice
and I don't actually I would I would
love a recommendation if if someone
knows of an excellent well-written you
know book with interesting narrative
diversions on the history of of
basically the spice trade
um but my sense in part is that um they
were all the spices were so so so
valuable uh for a while both because
they were new to the palettes of the
English and the other Colonial
Marauders and others
um but uh also because they were needed
to obscure the taste of rot yeah right
and also to to delay rot to some degree
and that as
um both refrigeration and of course
um the you know the processing and
plasticization of food developed over
the over the 20th century but as we're
no longer trying to reduce rot some you
know and spice became more available we
just sort of
obviously we didn't forget about like
everyone's got salt and pepper on their
table pretty much interesting that it
ended up being salt and pepper and that
therefore because most people have
pepper that's already ground sitting on
their on their table it adds almost
nothing right it just it right and and
yeah and you and you don't experience
that it is actually extraordinary and so
similarly you know a dash of a shrub or
just a or just a straight up vinegar
yeah to many foods adds a brightness and
a Sparkle and like it suddenly it makes
all the rest of the flavors yeah more a
lot and the difference between your
garbagey white vinegar and your
unfiltered cider vinegar is is quite big
it's again a place where the the common
thing is miles away from something that
isn't that expensive and uh it just has
a lot of character to it
yes yes indeed
okay
um another one giant herbs and teas for
their amazing chives and Bitters and
more these people are out of out of
Portland and they're delicious
absolutely delicious but they also come
with fantastic text to add a bit of good
spirited Stark and insight to your day
so I've got four of them here that I
wanted to share yes they are the most
heterodox of teas I would say yes so
we'll just start listen this is one that
I've been putting in cocktails the
coconero cocktail bitters
flavor notes a quick cacao front note
followed by a wickedly spicy finish
um and oh this one is just just an
excellent flavor this one doesn't have
any of the snark on it some of them do
some of them don't this is um
revolutionary evolutionary mole spiced
cocktail bitters
uh about which he has written
a complex system of flavors
confoundingly smooth with a spicy bit of
bite of Truth ahead of the herd
100 Agave a drop of Revolution and the
science of evolution
this is the importance one of his
tributes to us there was also Dark Horse
chai that he made in 2020 right and here
we have let's see let's go let's go with
this one first the whiffster whiffster
chai It's hard to say
Cameron looks weird
um a galangala lemongrass and ginger
chai if at first you don't get
antibodies try and try again a little
bit doesn't go a long way in fact you
will need more before three months are
up
uh and then on the back it says that's
great for us but not so great for your
tax dollars this chai does not stop
contraction transmission or sterilize
anything we actually don't know what the
long-term effects of drinking chai are
but if adults can drink it we think kids
should have it too if the Palace of the
F if our Pals at the FDA come through
for us we could have said secret
ingredients from 2021 to 2076
highly recommended that is
some quality snark how much that is he's
this is I mean and you know he's an
herbalist who really puts together
outstanding things and again this guy
out of Portland
um and the yeah the X the text that you
get these are herbalist but the text is
downright carnivorous indeed so this is
satire on fire chai uh we like to poke
fun at things going on because if we
can't laugh we are reduced by half it's
better than crying when things are so
trying enjoy a cup of fiery chai it will
help your day fly by I went with one
that wasn't so snarky just to show that
there's a little bit of a little bit of
uh poetry on most of these or Pros yep
fantastic think of how clever your
friends will think if you get them this
tea yeah indeed
okay next one yes anything to add no
nope where are we at we're about half an
hour in okay we're doing okay
um
the next one is different it's not a
thing but uh
but a set of things to read it's the
Slowdown Farmstead sub stack
written by my friend Tara Couture who
writes with bracing honesty in beautiful
prose about and these are her words from
the about page of slow down Farmstead
quote ancestral nutrition morals values
sovereignty and autonomy family
cultivating a life based on the lessons
I am told when my fingers are in the
earth my eyes to the sky and my heart
pressed against a tree
everything on this on slow down
Farmstead is is beautiful and much of it
is heart-wrenching uh among other true
things about
um Tara and her husband and the light
and their life at the moment is that
they are um so they live in uh rural
Ontario on a piece of land that they
have built into a producer of this year
everything they will be eating
and uh in you know in a Canadian winter
that's that's a challenge so they raised
and Slaughter and Butcher and prepare
cows and chickens and more and make
nutrient dense deliciousness and she
shares much of the process and many of
the recipes and uh and such on her site
Tara is also Tara and her husband are
also the mother of three daughters one
of whom just had her first baby their
first grandbaby uh and one of whose life
ended in May of 2021 which Tara wrote
about
um for natural selection this is my sub
stack in February of this year it's
called Mila's story and is as it should
be easily found on my sub stack as the
most popular
um post on Natural Selections it is
heartbreaking
um
a mother who can write with honesty
about the the death of her youngest
child
is extraordinary and so there is there
is ecstasy and despair and beauty and
love life and death on this on this site
and I highly recommend it
yeah um that story in particular is also
well worth uh well worth looking at yeah
yeah maybe I should add just that to
well if you can just go to my settings I
can find it right at the top it's right
there
okay
um
change of pace here
possets perfumes
did I forget those two okay I don't have
anything here
um
are unique handmade oil-based Indie
perfumes and they're lovely they have a
samples of the month club which gives
you access to many of their delightful
scents they are um they come from the
middle of the country somewhere I'm
forgetting where I want to say
Indiana or Kentucky I'm probably wrong
about that but they've got
here actually you can show my screen
here I'm on their site here
um not only do they have a number of
remarkable
sense and they also have all natural
sense and a sample of the month
subscription but they put the most
amazing art with each of their perfumes
mostly Old Masters or Classics and it
really could put you in mind you know
you you can't be driven by the scent
from a website because you have to go in
and read what the dominant notes are
what the ingredients are and even so
unless you're very experienced in
thinking about perfumery you're not
going to get there you need Luca turn to
translate you need Luca Turin and his uh
amazing uh perfume guide to help
translate
um but you know
from here we'll get to more oh there
aren't that many on that page
um
but
the Arts the the art associated with
them is okay you can take off my screen
now because I'm not finding anything
interesting
um
is a is a beautiful indicator of sort of
the diversity of the sense that they
offer
and it's also in some sense if we go
back to the initial discussion it's sort
of a measure of how thoughtful their
process is in producing this yeah right
and that you know I guess there are a
lot of little proxies that we don't know
we're processing but in this case the
point is yes it's Ascent but it was very
well thought out at the level of its
presentation as well and anyway that's
really cool no that's that's absolutely
true and they come in these little
they're they're not very expensive then
they come in these little blue bottles
to protect them from
um you know the blue is to protect them
from getting degraded by sunlight
presumably with labels which have little
tiny like thumbnails of the art that
they have representing that scent on
their site
and and the other samples are remarkable
you can get a whole a whole lot of them
and
you know if if you are sincerely
inclined and if hopefully you know you
still have your sense of smell after
covid uh you can be transported to a lot
of different places by you know just
taking a whiff of one and then a totally
different one like oh those put me in a
completely different mood actually
foreign
anymore actually
um the next one is
Pharaoh life so Pharaoh life was
actually a sponsor of ours but they're a
very small operation and they couldn't
um continue not because they don't like
us anymore because we don't like their
products because they do and we do
um but I wanted to make specific mention
of them here this is skin care products
it's a very small line I do have them
here we got skin food for the body
beautiful glass glass jars and what
they're calling face food for
the face
um
and their main ingredient is lard
it's not just any lard is loaf what
they're calling
um smart lard
made from pigs raised humanely outside
using regenerative farming practices
there's no water in these products
they're incredibly dense and and
it may sound like that's not what you
want to be putting on your body but
actually it's remarkable and if you have
any need at all for skin care products I
highly recommend these and if you have
someone in your life who and not just
you know not just the beautiful stuff
for your face that I like very much but
the skin food for if you are working
outside if you've got a baby who's
tending to be chapped
if you've got calluses if you've got dry
spots because you've got central heat
and it's winter and you're spending too
much time inside where the air is dry
this stuff is just fabulous yeah it's it
really works and if you think about it
yes all right the idea of lard is the
central ingredient is a little strange
at first but if you think about you know
go read the ingredients on some major
competitor yeah right and the question
is well then what are you putting on
your skin and is it transported Across
the Skin you know you don't know what it
is the point is a large list of
ingredients designed to produce
something to convince you to buy it and
to buy it again it's not necessarily
what you want from the point of view of
your well-being what you want is a very
simple natural product in which there's
no place for something to hide and I
would also point out these folks have a
great sense of humor about what they're
doing right they're not pretending their
product isn't what it is they lean into
it and Lord be with us exactly
um the lard works in mysterious ways
but you know
a you could just tell that they're good
people that they've chosen to do
something that's counterintuitive that
works they're they have a good time with
it yeah
um and the point is these things are all
proxies for something you're connecting
with people who uh are are deep I'm sure
if you sat down with these folks there
are a lot of other topics that they
would be interesting on oh and in fact
I've got a letter from the um the owner
operator of feral life that we received
that um perhaps you haven't seen but I
haven't yeah he's he's fantastic and
um so you know so we know
you know many of these people we
actually do have a an actual connection
with the giant herbs and teas guy and
the Slowdown Farmstead
um and I've interacted with the with the
wonderful
um people at possets perfumes as well
and yeah the Pharaoh life guy
um
is you know a dark horse fan who
um makes these remarkable products
because he cares deeply about
um you know human health and also uh
regenerative farming and also the you
know Ecology of the places where he
wants to spend time and frankly I'm I'm
all in right yeah
yeah all right uh I think the next thing
we want to talk about is that uh
fantastic creature over there yes all
right so I will first show you this was
a gift to us
from a good friend uh Ryan Bennett who
um there are a number of things about
this story so this is an orrery I'm
hoping I'm pronouncing it correctly
worry
um
is a description of an object in which
the
um things in the solar system parade
around when you uh activate it there's
an Ori
explicitly to scale
well it obviously can't be to scale in
one regard because it would you know the
distances between the objects can't be
right yeah but I believe it is accurate
with respect to the size of the objects
itself but is that inherent to
an artery as far as you know I'm not
certain okay but in any case
um so let's just say that this object
and actually you want to show the video
um here is a slightly more elaborate
version these are hand crafted by Ryan's
dad who's been doing this for decades
Ryan is our friend yes Ryan is our our
good friend Ryan is also I will just
point out a remarkable person in his own
right he
I believe I became aware of him he
showed up in my patreon group and he was
a little quiet at first but as he
started to uh say more it was clear that
this guy just had an incredibly sharp
mind
um he is a uh coder self-taught
um and he is I would argue the backup
plan if
um if Elon Musk fails to save the world
with free speech
um
uh yeah you wanna so let me just say
these objects made by Ryan's dad
um
are the real deal they're hand crafted
of fine materials you should be careful
though they are not cheap many people
will look at this site and know
immediately they can't afford such an
object
um even so I would say there is a link
at the bottom of this first page in
which you can put your email address
there are future projects
can you scroll to the bottom there's a
Kickstarter
project that you can sign up for
information on
in which other interesting science art
projects are going to emerge at various
different uh levels of expense so if
this is you and you can't afford it
which is pretty likely given that a
handcrafted object of this complexity is
not is not cheap anyway sign up for that
site and I would also just add a caution
here
um
these folks this genius family that
makes these beautiful objects
um
is facing a problem in which and this
goes straight to what you were talking
about at the beginning of this episode
um they are facing cheap knockoffs that
in fact abuse from across the Pacific
yes from across the Pacific that in fact
will take their imagery so a person will
order something for 60 bucks and think
that they're going to get a marvelous
object like this and they don't even get
an object that works like this and is
made mass produced they get some
disappointing thing that has nothing to
do with this and so in any case if you
go looking for this and you know if you
want one you got to go to the site to
find one that's real
um so you know that's a that's a sad
thing on the other hand these are clever
people and a campaign in which they are
producing many new projects some of
which you'll be able to build yourself
some of which will have other designs
that keeps ahead of competition which is
merely parroting what they find or in
this case
um producing something that
seems Loosely related but has nothing to
do with it
um in any case but a series of tragedies
we're living through yeah although on
the other hand
um it does
reveal something which is yes this sucks
a world in which you know your life's
work producing handmade art objects I
mean a beautiful thing what we are
headed into something like a dark age
isn't this exactly the sort of thing
that you want for a dark age when people
start believing crazy things about the
world don't you want a model of the
solar system with which to educate
children about what's actually uh out
there something I would also point out
and I think um I mean I maybe be too
small but when you're holding it up that
is it
um
is it
Neptune I can't figure out I can't quite
see which which of the planets has uh
the moon's orbiting there are two of
them and I think it's uh obviously
Saturn is a tilt we know this we know
this in our heads because of the Rings
but I think it's I think it's going to
be Uranus it's gonna be Pluto and Uranus
I believe yeah
um
but anyway doesn't count
Pluto totally does count and this orally
says so and it has is it Chiron I don't
know how to pronounce it actually
um the Pluto's Pluto's Pluto's orbiting
object
yeah they're so similar in size I don't
even know it's like it's there's I don't
know if it's really clear that it's that
as opposed to it's a it's a system of
two things that are doing this as they
go around the Sun orbiting each other I
mean all systems technically are but
um but you're right when they're very
different in size the yeah relative
motion of one versus the other is very
tiny right
um
but
you know this when I look at this thing
I sort of feel like oh that belongs in
Dumbledore's office right you would
expect that that would exist in
Dumbledore's office and it would have
magical properties and you would have to
be careful that fox the Phoenix didn't
uh become spooked and poop on it or
billions of people might die but you
know that sort of thing anyway it's that
kind of object and
um anyway I highly recommend that
whether this object is something you can
afford or not that you start tracking
these people and look at what they bring
uh to the table because it will all be
fascinating and you're supporting really
really high quality folks it's awesome
and that's at the scienceart.com website
which is also in the show notes yeah
um
yeah I guess I maybe I already said it
but I think the idea that this bad era
is surfacing excellent people is
um a powerful concept and so if what
you're looking for is uh highly unusual
folks doing things that you maybe didn't
think to expect or even desire right
that this is a good ERA for that because
the the the chaos and and falsity of the
rest of the system is driving them to
the surface indeed
all right
um
there's a couple more things
we and two of them are are ours uh one
of them is the set of things at our
store
uh and Zach is gonna Zach has pulled up
a few items um but basically at the Dark
Horse store
you can
um okay so we got welcome to complex
systems which is meta in more ways than
one variety of different products
cool okay so and that's a jacket looks
like we have epic Tabby one of my
favorites which also shows up on a tote
and our epic Debbie's hiding into the
bed at the moment not being very Epic no
um but it's not his most epic move no it
really he and his friend Tesla are both
hiding in the bed oh that's a nice bag I
haven't seen that bag before
um so that it's YouTube Community
guidelines because you can't handle the
truth um before you go on Zach I will
remind
um viewers that this store where these
products are being made the store itself
and the print shop where all the
printing and embroidery depending on the
product is happening are both
owned and run by a couple again in the
center of the United States
um they're fabulous and so again this is
a small Independent Producers um you
know we're we're we work with an amazing
artist and I will say that the art on on
these um is really fantastic and you
won't see the fantasticness of the art
online so as not to have the art stolen
for instance right
um but it really is absolutely
outstanding and then we send our
finalized thing once we've worked with
David our artist
um to um to squid print and uh and they
put the art on a variety of really high
quality products and also if you ever
have any issues that means that you know
you have someone that you will be able
to talk to how are we time-wise uh we
have
oh nine minutes so we have some time
because we yeah yeah so I wanted to add
something you can
yeah move on to the next product this is
uh our most recent one
um lie to a tyrant
and there's one more the
what I wanted to point out is a I've
always been troubled by the term
economies of scale I don't really
understand why economies is the word
that was chosen it seems like
efficiencies of scale would be the
natural way to say what economies of
scale means yeah um but I wanted to
point out that what we have here
is an inverse property and I'm sure it
has a name which I don't know but if you
think about the the comparison between
for example Teespring which which is
where we had our story where our store
was before where we now know having used
it and interacted with people who bought
things that effectively this is a giant
operation it's not even like there's a
Teespring Factory this thing takes uh
images and it puts it on products which
it somehow Farms out to some huge Market
of suppliers who are driven to reduce
the cost and therefore cut corners on
quality let me just say there is
something interesting that we actually
learned from Constance who was one of
the Proprietors of squid print which is
that Teespring basically hires
independent printers and basically like
okay I got it you know we got a job we
need 600 x or whatever or you know they
do it on demand so I don't know exactly
what how the order comes in but you can
apply if memory serves to be part of the
list of Teespring printers that they
will call but then you basically have to
be you know you have to do it if you get
called and what that means is that if
you are a very high quality printer as
squid print is who with whom we are now
working your work just gets disappeared
like you probably spend more on your
work and on your product because you're
a high quality printer but you don't is
no benefit for that right and so and and
so you would you expect anyone who's
participating in that system to either
start off with low quality work or lower
their quality of work in order to make a
living this is exactly what I'm trying
to point out is that the pressure to
cheapen the materials to not care how
long the Garment is going to last how
many Washings it will tolerate because
you don't get any credit for producing
the high quality thing right right that
pressure means that things that come
through that source which somebody on
the internet looking for a hoodie they
don't know yeah they don't know what
Teespring is right they just know if I
click this thing something arrives so
the point is here in this case what
we've found are real people who take
pride in their work have the opposite
incentive because the point is the
reputation of the goods actually does
come back to them in terms of people
wanting to order more things so
anyway the point is
it matters a whole bunch where this
stuff is coming from which is something
that we learned the hard way in a sense
because of what Teespring turned out to
be and what these people are as an
alternative yeah I remember for instance
like a couple of Dark Horse mugs that we
got early on that just started like they
started fading and you have some the
shirts they started like yeah I had a
shirt that didn't tolerate even one wash
very well so anyway
um we didn't know that we learned it the
same way others presumably did and I'm
sure some of the stuff didn't do that
right the point is what shop did it come
out of and the the thing to realize is
that in the comparison between two
suppliers that Teespring uses the one
that made the cheaper goods made the
bigger profit and the one that made the
better goods made the lower profit so
that system will evolve towards junk and
um the point is what what counteracts
that well ordering from people who
actually take pride in their work
because their work has their name on it
right and you know them establishing
relationship with us is the opposite
process it gives you it gives you
quality stuff it puts me in mind of
there being selective pressures
everywhere yes because there are and we
talk about that here which is the next
item on the list so this of course is
hunter-gatherer's Guide to the 21st
century it came out in September 2021 so
uh it's you know it's over a year old at
this point
um
100 gatherers guide the 21st century
Evolution and the challenges of Modern
Life it is at this point available in
several other languages as well and it's
going to be produced in in several more
in the next year and two we're still
we're still you know we just signed the
contract for the Swedish Edition
actually the Swedish Edition I'm looking
forward
website or not sure why not um and I
would I would point out actually this is
a a hidden feature of this book The
Swedish Edition no not the Swedish
Edition I know very little about how
this will be received in Sweden I don't
even know if you knew about the Swedish
station even though you said
schmoresport yesterday is that how you
pronounce it no you said smorgas I know
and I'm asking it sounded like the
Swedish Chef from the Muppets right uh
exactly
um but what I wanted to point out is
that
intuitively when you encounter this you
might think that um yeah this despite
the fact that we really oughten to be
this way we turn out to be polarizing
and therefore you might think that this
book would be good for some folks and
not good for other folks and it turns
out it's exactly the opposite because if
you give it to people who are heterodox
and think carefully they'll love it and
if you give it to the other folks they
can burn it
um actually no no right
um it it turns out
and I guess in the end I'm not that
surprised but I am disappointed that
many of the people in the so-called
heterodox community
can't abide evolutionary thinking once
it applies to human behavior
this is uh this is something we've seen
in Academia for many years uh we run
into it heck even many ecologists but
certainly many of the people in the
social sciences and Humanities really
don't like biologists coming in and
talking about what we learned about
sexual selection for instance from frogs
and spiders and birds and such and
saying hey and guess what
we can now say some things about for
instance the degree to which we have
sexual dimorphism in humans and what
that says about our past with monogamy
and polygyny and what that says about
our our now and what that says about how
much we can escape what we were handed
by Evolution and how much uh we can't
like we can't escape the sex binary but
we can't escape traditional gender roles
in part because many of the Traditions
than traditional gender roles aren't
that don't go that far back anyway
so
um
the book
uh is
a smorgasbord
and indeed this is a book that we have
been talking about writing for over a
decade at the point that at the point
that we wrote it and our agent came to
us not realizing that we had been
talking about writing this and said
there's too many things like we had
proposed several different books each of
us individually and the coupled together
and he said there's too many things that
you guys think about uh you should write
the everything book first the one that
has a little bit of all the kinds of
topics that you think about and so
indeed we have I'll just read the
chapter titles the human Niche a brief
history of the human lineage which goes
all the way back to the origin of life
ancient bodies Modern World Medicine
food sleep sex and gender Parenthood and
relationship Childhood school becoming
adults culture and Consciousness and the
fourth Frontier and the fourth Frontier
is our foray into societal level
evolutionary processes yes were we to
decide that the human experiment was
worth continuing this is a proposal for
how we might do that I've already
decided that it is you have yeah all
right congratulations and I'm not going
to read it here I actually am not sure
when Hanukkah starts this year but at
some point uh we probably will read this
again
um in the next week or two our epilogue
which is very short
involves uh our recounting of our
family's Hanukkah roles
um and the epilogue is about tradition
and how to tweak it we talk about the
value the necessity of of tradition of a
ritual the loss of traditional Ritual
from Modern Life but also the ways in
which what we have been handed are not
up to modernity and with that that
brings me to the very last thing that I
wanted to mention which I mentioned on
our very first ad episode is book Dart
so you can see there I've got a book
Dart
in the book they come in these sweet
little tins and a couple of metals and
they're just exactly what they sound
like they're little pieces of metal that
you put on a book to remind yourself of
something that you want to return to
that don't involve sticky notes that
don't involve pens or highlighters that
don't involve dog earring a page and you
can look you know this is our book and
so this just happens to be one copy that
has a couple of book darts in it but
some of the books that I return to over
and over again
I can be reminded of the state of mind I
was in when I read it in the past by
opening to where the book darts I say oh
that section oh why was I interested in
that section it does it you know it
doesn't appeal to me now or oh yes I get
it so it's it's a way of sort of adding
your own your own memories of and values
to a book it's interesting it
interestingly Bridges the gap between
the modern version right a a electronic
version of a book would allow you to
make a note to remove it later yep right
yep and the
prior World analog version in which you
might write in a book right but you
can't unwrite in the book right right
that is
altered here because the these things
are decidedly analog but they're also
not permanent and so you're current
thinking of what's interesting in the
book can evolve in the in the very same
copy you've been reading that's right
it's cool it is cool it's very cool uh
so I know we've forgotten some things uh
but that seems like a really good
set of objects and experiences and
values to share with you
at the beginning of this holiday season
2022 is there anything else you wanted
to say
um
might be worth just mentioning a few
other sub Stacks that are worth great
reading yeah uh I would say
you Holly okay so we got Natural
Selections Natural Selections uh we got
Holly sub stack which we talked about
and linked to in yesterday's show
um and I just I'm gonna call it up and
make sure I know what it's called
it's it is called oh it's called Holly
sub stick um and it's at Holly math
nerd.substack.com
um we've got uh
Dr Roller Gator who is which is called
what what
um
yeah Dr Roller Gator who apparently if
we are to read that's it
drilligator.substack.com but it's called
what what
oh yeah
um anyway Dr Roller Gator if we are to
uh understand
Elon musk's internal wiring is far worse
than Trump trump having been back on
Twitter
weeks ago and Dr relegater still
relegated to the dungeons okay
um Mike Solana pirate wires I recommend
that Mike is
wickedly smart rapidly funny yeah he's
really awesome
um it's a it's a gem uh
alexandros marinos if you want to see
somebody
who um grabs onto the hint of something
odd in the literature and chases it to
bedrock I don't think anybody beats Alex
at this he's just so good at it yeah
totally um and I know I
I hold on Zach we'll show that oh it's
yeah it's called do you do your own
research
yeah
um who else
there are many I was not prepared for
this I'm not I'm not going to add any
here because I will be guilty of yes
well let's put it this way to any that
we have forgotten and we will remember
four minutes after we're offline we
apologize this is obviously on the Fly
um but anyway those are some good ones
those are definitely uh worth reading
absolutely
um all right I think so in 10 minutes
we'll be back on air uh with a private
um you know patreon only q a the
questions have already been asked but we
are able to watch the chat as it happens
and interact to some degree with that
and we'll be on at 11 A.M Pacific here
for two hours
and maybe we will extract the cats from
under the beds and you can have some of
them some of the cat action and that
private private patreon
um if you do not join us there we will
be back at our regularly scheduled time
at noon 30 next Saturday for Dark Horse
live stream number I guess at that point
it'll be 1 53 this was 152 just now all
right so until we see you next time be
good to the ones you love eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
thank
you
foreign